well last night our report about one
South Valley High School had many of you
talking tonight records actually showed
that CCSD police responded dozens of
times to acts of violence there and this
has led to students being arrested even
one teenager filing a lawsuit saying he
was violently beaten Joshua peguero live
near Desert Oasis High School near
Rainbow and Cactus joining us with more
Joshua
Brian David yesterday I was at this
exact same school after I obtained audio
recordings of a teacher threatening to
harm a student today new documents shed
light on the violent incidents taking
place behind those closed doors
since the beginning of this school year
to mid-February school police responded
to 78 violent incidents at Desert Oasis
resulting in 22 criminal citations and
four arrests these students accused of
fighting and making threats we surrender
to the school district our children and
trust that they'll protect them and when
I hear numbers like that it is shocking
Matthew Holland of the cattle firm is
representing Fabian Fernandez and a
lawsuit filed in Clark County district
court on Wednesday Holland says in
October of 2021 Fernandez was assaulted
battered and physically injured by two
students he suffered serious injuries
including a fractured jaw that required
surgery fabian's medical expenses are
into the six figures of past medical
costs incurred the statutory cap that
protects CCSD is 150 000 the lawsuit
alleges administrators at Desert Oasis
knew of the violent behaviors of the
students both the district and Nevada
Department of Education are named in the
lawsuit Holland says the district
refused to settle Fernandez's claim as a
result of the SC his life has been
changed and his experience in the Clark
County School District forever has been
changed on Thursday we reported of a
lawsuit filed by another student
claiming his special education teacher
at Desert Oasis threatened him with harm
I just pick him up and just keep
slamming him into the floor
thank you
now Fabian Fernandez is currently at
another school helping him deal with his
post-traumatic anxiety reporting live in
a cactus and rainbow eight news now
Joshua thank you and Joshua reached out
to CCSD for comment on the lawsuit and
these violent incidents we're still
waiting at this time for a response